I grew up in like suburban Rancho
Cucamonga it was a lot of being bored
and figuring out what to do with myself
I learned to juggle knives I was in a
band I did puppetry I played baseball my
favorite movies were like the Shawshank
Redemption and about a boy and Forrest
Gump
what's it like to be the first to job'
director in Hollywood for a lot of
executives in the first 30 seconds they
think I'm going to talk with an accent
or they think I'm not gonna know about
normal things like there's a little like
sparkle of amusement different than what
I thought a regular Muslim person would
be like when I got into UCLA film school
I was so incredibly excited but I didn't
have any connections I just like well
I'm gonna try it and see how it goes
people are always telling these sob
stories about immigrants like things
like the namesake but the stories I grew
up hearing were hilarious so I was like
I wanted to do something with that
listen to me Sami be a great toy hunter
you must become like Tiger hunter is my
first feature film about a young man who
comes from India on this big quest for
success in America I interviewed my dad
I interviewed my mom I interviewed my
aunties and uncles in the community it's
called the tiger hunter because my
grandfather was a tiger hunter he has
the exact same moustache it was all kind
of based on truth my dad when he came
into this country all of his roommates
only had one epic suit maybe like
sitting in their underwear at home
scheduling their interviews around
availability this suit good job he was
hungry I tried so many strategies to
raise money for my movie it was like
pulling teeth first I tried South Asian
doctors and then film school people were
like okay try dentist because dentists
have doctor in their title and they want
to have that respect like doctors have
but they don't I send thousands of those
emails like they're cold emails I'd be
like hey I'm doing this movie I don't
know if you'll get your money back or
not but you and I can enter the industry
together how about that and then when my
executive proofs are called
and said all right I'm in for X amount
of money I think I was just like jumping
up or around my house like I ran into my
parents room and of course their
response was like don't count it until
it's in the bank like that was gonna be
a little movie and it suddenly became a
very big movie my sister-in-law she's
like oh my god you have to anybody
and all these people and that Kevin
Pollak was on board and Napoleon
Dynamite Jon Heder I was like okay now
I'm getting a little nervous we had this
huge crew everybody running around with
their walkie-talkies and you look out
and you're like this is my set like I'm
making a feature film and there is no
feeling like that that I think I've had
ever the cool thing that ended up
happening is that our crew became very
very diverse but black people we had
Asian people
we had women with a Sikh guy we had
Hindu guys we had bhai people we came
out in like 50 some theaters across the
country awesome reviews and things like
the New York Times we would be playing
in the middle of Virginia and it was
just such an amazing thing to see them
laughing along at the exact same parts
that like you know some Indian uncle
will be laughing along with I want to do
something good in the world and that's
sort of why I chose this profession it
doesn't see if people don't usually
think this profession is for that but it
totally can be like it can be a total
GameChanger now there's like people
helping me people with suits who get
things done I got attached to a direct
like this major Disney Feature do people
treat you differently now there's less
executives who when I walk in have that
30-second window where they're surprised
by everything I say that is not with an
accent and that is progress
[Applause]